hey guys it is the 25th of August today
my name is Jess Mitchell and you're
tuned into gamespot news Bungie has
revealed some of the new exotic items
that will be coming in the taken King
expansion for destiny today and they
look pretty sweet these include the
Imperium bellicose titan helmet which
will hold you in place while you're
aiming weapons in mid air warlocks will
be able to get the alchemist raiment
which gives you a chance to gain glimmer
while collecting primary ammo on the
weapon front there's the telescope usion
rifle which attaches projectiles to your
foes which detonate after a period of
time then there's the chaperone and
exotic shot gun which fires a single
shot but grants and agility boost and
gives you weapon buffs if you land
precision kills and the basically sounds
like the shotgun version of the most
useless exotic gun in the game right now
there no land beyond sniper rifle Tommy
may have cut metal gear creator Hideo
Kojima out of his own box art but the
veteran death hasn't been deterred
kadima 1052 on monday and tweeted out
thanks everyone i turned 52 and will
keep creating in the rest of my life
just where the dev will be headed next
is not yet known back in march sources
told GameSpot kajima would be departing
konami after the Phantom Pain's release
but we get to hear anything concrete
about Kachinas future a super impressive
graphics overhaul mod has revamped GTA 5
and it looks pretty incredible Mauro
Martin Bergman posted about his study
hamper mod on reddit calling it a work
in progress but much like the icenhancer
mod which beefed up the graphics and
textures of GTA 4 the screenshots
released for the mod so far look eerily
realistic Bergman said he used three
shade a generic post-processing injector
to improve the depth of field and color
correction of the game's graphics among
other
things the modder also said he added
some tone mapping and used the
post-processing middleware ENB to
implement high dynamic range lighting
let me know down in the comments what
you'd like to see Hideo Kojima work on
next you can add to gamespot or we've
got news on until dawn ps4 issues and
then you taken King teaser featuring
nolan north that is everything I want to
tell you about today be sure let me know
what mattered to you and I will see you
same time tomorrow